yo d'accord, alors quand vous m'avez rendu visite
en décembre de l'année dernière, j'avais cinq
employés, dont moi-même, maintenant j'ai
plus de 40 employés qui se composent de
cultivateurs de cultivateurs ainsi que de personnel formé à l'
entretien des bourgeons, les bourgeons auxquels nous avons en
quelque sorte pris ce nom  être similaire
à une grosse tumeur mais les budtenders sont
très entraînés ils connaissent bien nos produits
ils sont tous des consommateurs de cannabis et
leur travail principal est de demander au client
quel est son résultat quel est le
résultat souhaité et ensuite ils personnaliseront
leurs recommandations  en fonction de ce que
le client recherche, des effets
recherchés par les clients, c'est donc un poste très qualifié,
très professionnel et c'est
un poste très souhaitable, beaucoup de gens
ne peuvent pas croire qu'ils peuvent réellement
avoir un emploi où les impôts ont été prélevés
là où ils  Je vends de la marijuana, donc
c'est une belle chose, nous sommes conscients que nous
avons également deux scientifiques dans le personnel maintenant,
donc c'est une large gamme de compétences,
mais les offres de bourgeons sont très
populaires  position ar et souhaitable au sein de
l'industrie et quel est le travail des
scientifiques les scientifiques doivent
déterminer quelles sont les meilleures souches
déterminer quelle est la composition chimique de
certains des produits que nous
obtenons pour développer de nouveaux produits um nouvelle
génétique de meilleures façons  de cultiver, je
pense que la culture du cannabis dure depuis plus de 10 ans
maintenant et chaque fois que nous faisons une pièce, nous faisons
quelque chose d'un peu différent, donc c'est une
sorte de processus évolutif en ce qui concerne
la culture et à mesure que l'industrie
mûrit, de plus en plus de produits et de
lignes de nutriments montent le sol  mélanges et tout le monde
veut que nous essayions leurs produits pour cultiver
notre cannabis, c'est donc un processus
constant d'essayer de s'améliorer en essayant de faire
mieux que la dernière fois